Talking is easy. Listening, not so much. When we think about conversation, we tend to focus on the speaker, his or her ideas, words, gestures, and emotions. But psychologists' research suggests that often it's the listener who sets the tone of such interactions. Quality listening can strengthen relationships and build bridges between people, while poor listening can do the opposite. So what is high quality versus low quality listening? Why is listening well, so much harder than it sounds? How can good listening skills help us in our relationships, workplaces, and communities? And what are the limits of listening as a tool for understanding each other? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association
说话很容易，但倾听却没那么简单。当我们思考对话时，往往会关注说话者，关注他们的想法、言辞、手势和情绪。但心理学研究表明，通常是倾听者决定了此类互动的基调。高质量的倾听可以加强人际关系并架起沟通的桥梁，而糟糕的倾听则会适得其反。那么，什么是高质量的倾听，什么是低质量的倾听？为什么善于倾听听起来容易，做起来却这么难？良好的倾听技巧如何帮助我们改善人际关系、职场表现和社区生活？作为一种相互理解的工具，倾听又有哪些局限性？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，
that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Guy Ichikoff, a professor in the Department of Human Services at the University of Haifa. where he directs the interpersonal listening and social influence lab. His research focuses on how high-quality listening
旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。今天的嘉宾是海法大学公共服务系教授盖伊·伊奇科夫博士，他在该校指导人际倾听与社会影响实验室。他的研究重点是高质量的倾听如何
affects listeners and speakers' emotions, attitudes, and behaviors, and how listening drives interactions in settings, ranging from close relationships to workplaces. His work has appeared in leading journals and publications, including the Journal of Personality and Social Psychology, emotion, and the Harvard Business Review. He also writes a blog for psychology, today called The Listening Lens.
影响倾听者和说话者的情绪、态度和行为，以及倾听如何推动从亲密关系到职场等各种环境下的互动。他的研究成果发表在《人格与社会心理学杂志》、《情绪》以及《哈佛商业评论》等领先期刊和出版物上。他还为《今日心理学》撰写了一个名为“倾听之镜”的博客。
Dr. Itchikoff, thank you for joining me today. Thank you for inviting me. I'm really happy to be here. Let's start with a basic question. What is high quality listening and what distinguishes it from just everyday listening to another person talk? It is both a basic and complex question because there was a study back in 1989
伊奇科夫博士，感谢您今天参加我们的节目。谢谢您的邀请，我很高兴能来到这里。让我们从一个基本问题开始。什么是高质量的倾听？它与日常生活中听别人说话有什么区别？这是一个既基础又复杂的问题，因为早在1989年就有一项研究
that tried to organize the definitions of what is good listening between interpersonal listening, between people. And even back then, they found more than 50 different definitions for what listening is. But in a nutshell, what differentiate high quality listening from ordinary listening or everyday listening is the listeners attempt to really understand the speaker and a positive, a positive intention toward the speaker. So this is what Carl Rogers referred to back in the, more than 60 years ago as a non-judgmental approach, meaning that I don't necessarily have to agree with what I hear and we all, we have an inner need to evaluate what we hear. However,
试图整理人际交往中什么是良好倾听的定义。即使在当时，他们也发现了关于倾听的50多种不同定义。但简而言之，高质量倾听与普通倾听或日常倾听的区别在于，倾听者是否真正试图理解说话者，以及对说话者是否持有积极的意图。这就是卡尔·罗杰斯在60多年前所说的“非评判性态度”，意思是说，我不一定非要同意我所听到的内容，我们每个人内心都有评估所闻的需要。然而，
listeners can convey that it is, the speaker has the, the speaker has the freedom and the autonomy to express what they say. And when these three dimensions, which manifest in many behaviors are executed well, people feel heard. They feel listened to and there is a plenthora, a fountain of positive outcomes for them. One of the main themes of your work is a good listening deeply affects not just the listener, but the speaker as well. What happens to people psychologically when they feel truly listened to, when they feel heard? So yeah, most of our work has focused on people being listened to. So yeah, as you mentioned, on the speakers. And the psychological process that we see that is happening, especially in live
倾听者可以传达出说话者拥有表达自我的自由和自主权。当这三个维度（体现在许多行为中）执行得很好时，人们会感到被倾听。他们会感到被理解，这对他们来说有着无穷无尽的积极成果。您工作的主要主题之一是良好的倾听不仅深刻影响倾听者，也深刻影响说话者。当人们感到真正被倾听、被理解时，他们在心理上会发生什么？是的，我们的大部分工作都集中在被倾听的人身上，也就是说话者。我们实验室研究的核心是，在现场
conversations, which is the core of the studies in my lab, is that first, specifically speakers relax their state anxiety, state social anxiety, evaluation, apprehension reduce. They feel more socially comfortable because of the listening that they receive. Now, this relaxation, this social comfort, if you will, allows them to introspect, think more deeply about what they are saying. And of course, none of this could have been achieved without a good listener. Now, when they experience such listening,
对话中，我们观察到的心理过程是：首先，说话者的状态焦虑、社交焦虑和评价忧虑会减轻。由于得到了倾听，他们会感到更加自在。这种放松，或者说社交舒适感，使他们能够进行内省，更深入地思考他们所说的话。当然，如果没有一个好的倾听者，这一切都不可能实现。现在，当他们体验到这种倾听时，
so this emotional process that leads to this cognitive process of deeper introspection and ability to look at myself from the side and often gain clarity, gain even complexity to see that what I initially thought what my initial edited was, there are other aspects, often, by the way, contradictory to my initial attitude. This is why we often find that experiencing good listening
这种情绪过程会引导出更深层次内省的认知过程，使他们能够从旁观者的角度审视自己，并往往能获得清晰的认识，甚至能看到复杂性，意识到我最初的想法或态度其实还有其他方面，顺便说一下，这些方面往往与我最初的态度相矛盾。这就是为什么我们经常发现体验到良好的倾听
reduces extremity of attitudes. Now, this relax, so basically this comfort or relaxation broadens the thinking. And this broadening of the thinking, allows for more complex, more open-minded introspection, which then leads to many attitudinal and behavioral consequences. So this is an after the process that one of the processes that we see, we also see a very strong shift in positive emotions.
会降低态度的极端性。这种放松，或者说舒适感，拓宽了思维。而这种思维的拓宽，使得内省更加复杂、更加开放，从而导致许多态度和行为上的改变。这是我们观察到的过程之一，我们还观察到积极情绪的强烈转变。
One of the most, the interesting findings that we have is reduction in negative emorphins. For example, in one of the project, we had five studies where the topic was the effect of listening on speakers' state loneliness. And the speakers shared an experience where they felt socially rejected. Now, this was really interesting because I initially thought that, okay, but if you could, share something that happened to you 20 years ago, it might not be relevant, but we were surprised to see how much the social rejection when people talk about it,
我们发现的最有趣的结论之一是负面情绪的减少。例如，在一个项目中，我们进行了五项研究，主题是倾听对说话者状态孤独感的影响。说话者分享了他们感到被社会排斥的经历。这非常有趣，因为我最初想，好吧，如果你分享的是20年前发生的事情，可能没什么意义，但我们惊讶地发现，当人们谈论社会排斥时，
it still affects them. Now, when we compared, and we're doing live conversations, when we compared speakers who conversed with a listener who provided high-quality listening, we found that they reported significantly and very strong effect on reduced, on reduction in state loneliness relative to participants who conversed with a moderate listener, listener who provided average or moderate quality
它仍然会影响他们。当我们进行现场对话并比较那些与提供高质量倾听的倾听者交谈的说话者时，我们发现，与那些与提供一般或中等质量倾听的倾听者交谈的参与者相比，他们的状态孤独感显著降低。
listening. And this effect, by the way, was explained in this project through increased in how related relatedness they felt towards their listener, basically how socially connected. they felt towards their listener and the extent to it they felt autonomy. So the extent to it, they felt that they have the right to express, to genuinely express their thoughts. A lot of people have heard the term active listening, right, a technique of reflecting back what someone says,
顺便说一下，这个项目通过他们对倾听者的亲近感（即他们感到与倾听者的社会联系程度）以及他们感受到的自主权程度（即他们感到有权真实表达自己想法的程度）来解释这种效果。很多人都听说过“积极倾听”这个词，对吧？这是一种复述别人所说内容的技巧，
you paraphrase and ask questions. But you've written about the limitations of active listening as it's often taught and practice. So what is the difference between active listening and high quality listening? Listening has so many adjectives. I don't think that there is another social behavior that has as many adjectives as listening, active, empathic, supportive. Now, if you think about it, one of the interesting thing that we infer, when we say active listening is actually a misperception, that listening is passive.
你进行意译并提出问题。但你写过关于积极倾听在教学和实践中存在的局限性。那么，积极倾听和高质量倾听有什么区别？倾听这个词有太多的形容词了。我不认为还有哪种社交行为像倾听这样有这么多形容词：积极的、共情的、支持性的。如果你仔细想想，我们在说“积极倾听”时推断出的一个有趣的事情，实际上是一种误解，即认为倾听是被动的。
because we would never say active speaking. Of course speaking is active, of course. But for listening, in order for listening to feel special, we need to say it's active. Now, I know this is the most frequently used adjective. And so, yeah, I wrote about it in one of my blogs. I thought, like, what would Carl Rogers, who coined the term, think about how active listening,
因为我们永远不会说“积极说话”。当然，说话是积极的。但对于倾听，为了让它感觉特别，我们需要说它是“积极的”。我知道这是最常用的形容词。所以，我在我的博客中写过关于它的内容。我想，卡尔·罗杰斯（这个词的创造者）会怎么看待积极倾听呢？
and it's a very powerful technique. It's one of many listening techniques. The issue is, as I mentioned, that the name incorporates the misperception that listening is passive. And it is really, it really depends how it is practiced. Because if we want to achieve deep conversations, help or have social connection with the other person, we need a genuine intention or a positive intention or something. sometimes even call like a listening attitude, my assumption that by listening alone, I will help the other person. Now, when this becomes too technical, so like every time I give an interview, they ask me, okay, now give me the tips, how to be a good listener.
这是一种非常强大的技巧。它是众多倾听技巧中的一种。问题正如我所提到的，这个名字包含了一种误解，即认为倾听是被动的。它确实取决于它是如何实践的。因为如果我们想实现深度对话，帮助他人或与他人建立社会联系，我们需要一种真诚的意图、积极的意图，或者有时被称为“倾听态度”，即我假设仅仅通过倾听，我就能帮助对方。现在，当这变得过于技术化时——比如每次我接受采访，他们都会问我：“好吧，现在给我一些建议，如何成为一个好的倾听者。”
So this is, there are tips, but it's basically saying, give me the tips on how to be a good swimmer. You have to practice it. Right. Now, so the behaviors are very powerful, very powerful, question asking, paraphrasing, validation, the back channel behavior. The issue is, are they really genuine and authentic? And here, I think that what I wrote about is Rogers didn't even often disagree to give talks about the active listening because every conversation was different. for him.
所以，建议是有，但这就好比问“给我一些建议，如何成为一个好的游泳者”。你必须去练习。行为是非常强大的，提问、意译、确认、反馈行为都很强大。问题是，它们是否真的真诚和真实？在这里，我认为我写的是，罗杰斯甚至经常拒绝就积极倾听发表演讲，因为对他来说，每一次对话都是不同的。
So he refused to give a checklist. And there is a paper from 2011, not my paper, but a really interesting paper on how organizations, some organizations use active listening techniques to manipulate customers because it's very powerful. So what I wrote was like, what would Carl Rogers think about active listening today?
所以他拒绝提供清单。2011年有一篇论文，不是我的，但非常有趣，关于一些组织如何利用积极倾听技巧来操纵客户，因为它非常强大。所以我写的是，卡尔·罗杰斯今天会怎么看待积极倾听？
So I'm all in favor and we're doing all of these behavior. in my lab and when I give workshops, very powerful. The issue is, is the intention of the listener really to help the speaker or to get the speaker to somewhere that I wanted to get them before? Now, this is a key difference in my experience. That brings to mind what you run into a lot today, which is, you know, you call customer service and about the second or third question is, what's your name? and then they want to call you by your name over and over again,
我完全赞成，我们在实验室里也在做所有这些行为，当我举办研讨会时，它们非常强大。问题是，倾听者的意图真的是为了帮助说话者，还是为了把说话者带到我预想的地方？这是我经验中的一个关键区别。这让我想起了你今天经常遇到的情况，你知道，你给客服打电话，第二个或第三个问题就是“你叫什么名字？”，然后他们想一遍又一遍地叫你的名字，
as if that indicates that they're somehow more empathetic. I mean, is there anything to that? Is repeating the speaker's name something that is going to make them feel they're listened to? We tried it in some of our experiment where we mentioned the name again. It helps, but like most of the things, it helps if you do it to the right extent. For example, it's like nodding. So when someone nuts when I speak, at the beginning I'm going to probably think,
好像这表明他们更有同理心。我的意思是，这有什么意义吗？重复说话者的名字会让他们觉得被倾听了吗？我们在一些实验中尝试过再次提到名字。这有帮助，但像大多数事情一样，如果你在适当的程度上做，它才会有帮助。例如，这就像点头。当我在说话时有人点头，起初我可能会想，
okay, they're paying attention. But if I see them going like this with their head, the entire dog, you know there is this doll of a dog. You put in the dashboard of your car that goes with the head when you drive. So it, or when someone says, mm-hmm, mm-hmm. So all of this behavior, they're good if they're in the right time and space during the conversation. If I do them artificially or overdo them,
好吧，他们在注意听。但如果我看到他们一直这样点头，就像那种放在汽车仪表盘上的摇头狗玩偶，或者当有人一直说“嗯哼，嗯哼”。所有这些行为，如果它们出现在对话中合适的时间和空间，它们是好的。如果我人为地做这些，或者做得过火，
I will often interrupt my speaker because if I say their name too much, it sounds a bit weird or it sounds like they're, because this doesn't happen in everyday conversations. Or even if I say, mm-hmm, mm-hmm, mm-hmm, or nod my head, the entire conversation, we're coming again to the authentic nature, of the listeners.
我经常会打断我的说话者，因为如果我太频繁地叫他们的名字，听起来会有点奇怪，或者听起来像是在……因为这在日常对话中不会发生。或者即使我一直说“嗯哼”或一直点头，我们又回到了倾听者真实性的问题上。
So like every psychologist, the answer is yes and no. Yes, it helps, but not to overdo it. What role does listening play in maintaining close relationships with our partners, families, and friends? This is what my research has focused on for the past 15 years.
所以，像每个心理学家一样，答案是肯定的，也是否定的。是的，它有帮助，但不要做得过火。倾听在维持与伴侣、家人和朋友的亲密关系中起什么作用？这就是我过去15年研究的重点。
I think that listening is the spark for social connection, the spark in the sense that we all want to feel socially connected to others. The question is, how do we do it? I cannot just tell people, okay, now you connect.
我认为倾听是社会联系的火花，这种火花意味着我们都希望与他人建立社会联系。问题是，我们该怎么做？我不能只是告诉人们，“好吧，现在你们建立联系吧。”
I need to give people, you know, a technique, a tool, and what I consistently find in my lab that when people feel listened to, they feel socially connected to the other person. And we found it using so many different constructs of social connection. And one of the reasons that this happens, I often ask them to say, like, why?
我需要给人们一个技巧、一个工具。我在实验室里始终发现，当人们感到被倾听时，他们会感到与对方在社会上是相连的。我们使用许多不同的社会联系结构发现了这一点。我经常问他们，“为什么？”
Why does listening, because we know it increases social connection between the speaker and the listener? One of the interesting thing about listening is that it sends meta messages. A meta message is a message that is not conveyed through words. For example, one of the mistakes that listeners do is telling their speakers, I know what you mean. Now, every time I say it, it sounds really weird.
为什么倾听会增加说话者和倾听者之间的社会联系？关于倾听，有趣的一点是它会发送“元信息”。元信息是一种不是通过语言传达的信息。例如，倾听者犯的错误之一是告诉说话者“我明白你的意思”。现在，每次我说这句话时，听起来都很奇怪。
Why? But I know what you mean. So the mistake here is that often when I say, I know what you mean, one of two things happens or both. I become the speaker instead of the speaker instead of the language. listener. Yes, Kim, I know what you mean. Something similar happened to me a while ago and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. And then I become the speaker. Now, a more subtle, but very powerful mistake. And this is, I'm saying a mistake, but it's human and it's, it's natural. The thing is, this is this is why listening requires training, is when I think I know what you mean, I stop listening to you. And I, if I'm patient and I'm polite, I'm waiting until you finish, but I, I close my ears,
为什么？但我确实明白你的意思。这里的错误在于，当我说“我明白你的意思”时，通常会发生两件事中的一件，或者两者兼有。我变成了说话者，而不是倾听者。是的，金，我明白你的意思。不久前我也发生过类似的事情，巴拉巴拉……然后我就变成了说话者。现在，一个更微妙但非常强大的错误——我说这是一个错误，但它是人性化的，是自然的。问题是，这就是为什么倾听需要训练，当我以为我明白你的意思时，我就停止倾听你了。如果我有耐心且礼貌，我会等你讲完，但我会关闭我的耳朵，
metaphorically. And when I do listening training, I often, when we challenge this assumption, really, because you and I can share a similar experience, but the subjective experience would be completely different for us, even if we use the same emotion. The extent to which I say, I felt excited, and you'll say I felt excited,
隐喻意义上的。当我进行倾听训练时，我们挑战这种假设，真的吗？因为你和我可以分享类似的经历，但即使我们使用相同的情绪，主观体验也会完全不同。我表达“我感到兴奋”的程度，和你表达“我感到兴奋”的程度，
is completely different for both of us. In order to really step into the person's shoes, the speaker's shoes, I need to challenge this basic assumption and Rogers call it the need to evaluate. What we, oh, I understand what Kim said. I'm patient. I will, I will, I will, I till until she finishes,
对我们两人来说是完全不同的。为了真正站在对方的立场上，我需要挑战这个基本假设，罗杰斯称之为“评估的需要”。我们想，“哦，我明白金说了什么。我有耐心。我会等她说完，
and then I will tell her what I think. This is where miscommunication happens. Because when we challenge this assumption, we often realize that what we initially thought we understood is not what the speaker meant. Now, the reason I went to this misperception, this is only one misperception. I know saying, I know what you mean,
然后我会告诉她我的想法。”这就是沟通不畅发生的地方。因为当我们挑战这个假设时，我们经常意识到我们最初以为自己理解的，并不是说话者真正的意思。现在，我之所以提到这种误解——这只是其中一种误解——“我明白你的意思”，
is basically like saying, trust me. No one will trust me if I actually say trust me. This is a direct message. A meta message is a message that is conveyed through behaviors. So during a conversation, when the listener exhibits high quality listening, using many behaviors, but they signal to their speakers,
基本上就像说“相信我”。如果我真的说“相信我”，没人会相信我。这是一个直接信息。元信息是通过行为传达的信息。因此，在对话过程中，当倾听者表现出高质量的倾听，使用许多行为，但他们向说话者发出信号：
you belong, you are important. when I paraphrase what you're saying and I ask you at the end, Kim, did I understand you correctly? Did they miss anything? I don't need to tell you, I understand you. You will feel that I understand you. And this is that these meta messages, you belong, you are competent, you are worthy of my time, builds a sense that we call togetherness.
“你属于这里，你很重要。”当我意译你所说的话，并在最后问你：“金，我理解对了吗？我漏掉了什么吗？”我不需要告诉你“我理解你”。你会感觉到我理解你。这些元信息——你属于这里，你有能力，你值得我花时间——建立了一种我们称之为“共处感”的感觉。
So just to shift a little bit, I think some people are just innately really good listeners and some people, they're not. And I'm just wondering, what are the personality characteristics of a good listener? And if you're, say, a narcissist, can you be a good listener? So the short answer is actually, yes. Research to date has not found a personality characteristic that differentiates between good and poor listeners. And many studies try because they're often the assumption that makes sense that, you know, if a person is extroverted, maybe they will be poor listeners because they want to speak more. And maybe if someone is introverted, they will be better listeners.
那么，稍微转换一下话题，我认为有些人天生就是很好的倾听者，而有些人则不是。我只是想知道，一个好的倾听者有哪些人格特征？如果你是一个自恋者，你能成为一个好的倾听者吗？简短的回答是：实际上，是的。迄今为止的研究尚未发现能区分好倾听者和差倾听者的特定人格特征。许多研究都试图寻找，因为通常的假设是合理的，比如，如果一个人外向，也许他们会是差的倾听者，因为他们想说得更多。也许如果一个人内向，他们会是更好的倾听者。
There was some study that found that people who are high on agreeableness are better or perceived as better listeners. But overall, personality traits are not so associated with being perceived and as a better listener. as a good listening. What actually matters here is it's a skill. It's a skill. It's a muscle that requires training. And when you train this muscle, whether you're a narcissist or you're an introvert or an extrovert or whatever, you will become better at listening. One of the more the interesting findings from a paper led by my colleague and supervisor, Avi Kluger, was that we found in a study that listening is actually diadic. So meaning that being perceived as a good listener depends on the person that I'm talking to.
有一些研究发现，宜人性高的人是更好的倾听者，或者被认为更好的倾听者。但总的来说，人格特质与被认为是一个好的倾听者并没有太大的关联。真正重要的是，这是一种技能。这是一种肌肉，需要训练。当你训练这块肌肉时，无论你是自恋者、内向者还是外向者，你都会变得更善于倾听。我同事兼导师阿维·克鲁格领导的一篇论文中一个更有趣的发现是，我们发现倾听实际上是“二元”的。这意味着，被认为是一个好的倾听者取决于我正在与之交谈的人。
So for example, I can be a great listener to my neighbor perceived as a great listener to my neighbor, but the horrible listener perceived as a horrible listener to you. So the perception of listening quality depends on the listener speaker diet. This is what we often find that it's, we tested this question like, okay, is there something in the person that makes them being perceived as good listeners or the speaker? Or maybe there's something in the speaker that some people are just easier to listen to. So so far we didn't find so much effect on the, it's mostly diadic. Now, if I may, another interesting finding that we recently wrote about it in a paper in
例如，我可以是一个伟大的倾听者，被我的邻居认为是一个伟大的倾听者，但被你认为是一个糟糕的倾听者。因此，对倾听质量的感知取决于倾听者与说话者的二元关系。我们经常发现，我们测试过这个问题，比如，“是一个人身上有什么特质让他们被认为是一个好的倾听者，还是说话者身上有什么特质？或者说话者身上有什么特质让某些人更容易被倾听？”到目前为止，我们没有发现太多关于个人的影响，它主要是二元的。现在，如果可以的话，我们最近在论文中写的另一个有趣的发现，
about, we call it the puzzles of listening, the contradictions and paradoxes in listening research. What is interesting is in conversations between strangers, the association between how the listener perceives their listening quality, how a speaker perceives how well they were listened to, and how an observer perceives the conversation, the associations are small to moderate, and we found it in several works that we conducted,
关于我们称之为“倾听的谜题”，即倾听研究中的矛盾和悖论。有趣的是，在陌生人之间的对话中，倾听者如何感知自己的倾听质量、说话者如何感知自己被倾听的程度，以及观察者如何感知对话，这些关联性是小到中等的，我们在我们进行的多项工作中都发现了这一点，
which really, you know, raises an interesting question, like, do people live in different worlds? Like, are we in the same? Listeners tend to overestimate how well they listen. I read this paper that had people rate their ability in everyday behaviors and listening was the behavior that they rated that they are at the top. So 71% rated themselves above the midpoint of scale between zero to 100.
这确实提出了一个有趣的问题，比如，人们生活在不同的世界吗？我们是在同一个世界吗？倾听者倾向于高估他们倾听得有多好。我读过这篇论文，让人们评价他们在日常行为中的能力，倾听是他们评价自己处于顶端的那种行为。71%的人将自己评价在0到100分量表的中间点之上。
I looked at this paper and they said, wow, this is really strong. But I wonder, what, is it that strong? I replicated this effect and found 92.3% of the people that reported more than the midpoint of the scale. Now, this is interesting because there are other papers showing that people at work, especially women and people who do not hold the managerial role, perceived that they're not satisfied by the listening effort that they receive. So, wait, we have all these terrific listeners, and at the same time, we have speakers who do not feel heard. But these are the same people. So, like, you know, this is a puzzle that is really, for me, is really interesting to further explore. We're going to take a short break.
我看了这篇论文，他们说，哇，这真的很强。但我怀疑，它真的那么强吗？我重复了这个实验，发现92.3%的人报告的分数高于量表的中间点。这很有趣，因为有其他论文显示，在工作中，特别是女性和不担任管理角色的人，认为他们对所得到的倾听努力不满意。所以，等等，我们有这么多出色的倾听者，同时我们又有感觉没被倾听的说话者。但这些人是同一群人。所以，你知道，这是一个对我来说非常有趣的谜题，值得进一步探索。我们要休息一下。
When we return, I'll talk with Dr. Itchikov about what happens when two people disagree but still feel listened to and about how high quality listening can defuse extremism. So I want to talk about disagreements, which is an area where you've done a lot of research. and you've found that high quality listening can make people feel less defensive and less extreme in their views. What are the reasons for that? So the reasons are twofold. The first reason is the one that we talked about before
回来后，我将与伊奇科夫博士讨论当两个人意见不合但仍感到被倾听时会发生什么，以及高质量的倾听如何化解极端主义。所以我想谈谈分歧，这是你做了很多研究的一个领域。你发现高质量的倾听可以让人感到不那么防御，对自己的观点也不那么极端。原因是什么？原因有两个。第一个原因是我们之前谈到的
and experience of social connection with the speaker. You know, when you come to a conversation, when you know or you realize that the person disagrees, one of the fears that comes is psychological reactants. I feel that my freedom to hold my attitude might be threatened. I feel that I might not be perceived
与说话者的社会联系体验。你知道，当你进行对话时，当你意识到对方不同意你的观点时，产生的恐惧之一是“心理抗拒”。我觉得我持有自己态度的自由可能受到威胁。我觉得我可能不会被认为
as competent or self-war or my self-esteem. How will I represent myself? Because this is a situation. This is a disagreement is a stress-evoking situation. Now, what we found is when speakers conversed with listeners who exhibited high quality listeners, they reported increased positivity resonance.
是有能力的，或者我的自尊心受到影响。我将如何代表我自己？因为这是一个情境。分歧是一个引发压力的情境。现在，我们发现，当说话者与表现出高质量倾听的倾听者交谈时，他们报告了更高的“积极共鸣”。
Positiveity resonance is a really interesting construct that depicts social connection in a conversation. So to what extent did they feel the flow between myself and the listener? To what extended, they feel that mutual emotions and thoughts, even though we disagree. So the first step was the connection that reduces the threat. So I don't feel threatened anymore.
积极共鸣是一个非常有趣的结构，描述了对话中的社会联系。所以，他们感受到我和倾听者之间的流动程度如何？尽管我们意见不合，但他们感受到共同的情绪和想法的程度如何？所以第一步是减少威胁的联系。所以我不再感到受威胁了。
I feel accepted. I feel connected to the person even though we disagree. Then this led to an increase in self-insight. Self-insight is to what extent did I manage to think of my attitude from different perspectives? To what extent did I, was I able to explore my attitude? in a deeper sense. To what extent did they learn new things
尽管我们意见不合，但我感到被接受，感到与那个人有联系。然后这导致了“自我洞察力”的增加。自我洞察力是指我能在多大程度上设法从不同的角度思考我的态度？我在多大程度上能够探索我的态度？在更深层次上。我在多大程度上学到了新东西
about my attitude? So this is the cognitive process that maybe like the more open-minded. Increased self-insight was the more open-minded thinking. And this led to a reduction in attitude extremity. So participants rated their attitude more, less extreme. We measured it before,
关于我的态度？所以这是认知过程，也许就像更开放的思维。增加的自我洞察力是更开放的思维。这导致了态度极端性的降低。所以参与者将他们的态度评价得不那么极端。我们在对话前测量了
their attitude before the conversation and also afterwards. And interestingly, they also measured, like we measured self-reported attitude change. To what extent did you feel that your attitude towards the issue changed? And we found that they reported that their attitude has changed. And also that it became more similar to their listeners attitude. Now, this was really interesting because the listener did not convey any persuasive attempt.
他们的态度，之后也测量了。有趣的是，他们还测量了——我们测量了自我报告的态度改变。你在多大程度上感到你对这个问题的态度改变了？我们发现他们报告说他们的态度改变了。而且它变得更接近他们倾听者的态度。现在，这非常有趣，因为倾听者没有传达任何说服意图。
If you think about it, this is exactly the opposite of arguments or of destructive conversations. because, and this is how the core idea I had for this study. We live in a world of destructive conversations, which leads to a lot of polarization. Now, the psychological process that works, that operates in destructive conversation or in arguments, is the opposite of listening. When someone is arguing with me
如果你仔细想想，这与争论或破坏性对话恰恰相反。因为，这就是我进行这项研究的核心想法。我们生活在一个充满破坏性对话的世界里，这导致了大量的两极分化。现在，在破坏性对话或争论中运作的心理过程，与倾听恰恰相反。当有人在和我争论
and is telling me that I'm wrong, I'm not able to listen to them. I initially defend psychologically, like if someone would come into my house, they would physically defend. When someone threatens my right and freedom and autonomy to hold a position, I defend psychologically.
并告诉我我错了时，我无法倾听他们。我最初会进行心理防御，就像如果有人闯进我的房子，他们会进行身体防御一样。当有人威胁我持有立场的权利、自由和自主权时，我会进行心理防御。
Now, when they speak, I'm not really listening to them. I'm thinking of counter arguments, how I'm going to, act back, how I'm going to win, right? I'm going to need to win this conversation. There is no prize, but I need to win this conversation. And this evokes defensiveness.
现在，当他们说话时，我并没有真正倾听他们。我在思考反驳的论点，我将如何反击，我将如何获胜，对吧？我需要赢得这场对话。虽然没有奖品，但我需要赢得这场对话。这引发了防御心理。
Now, we often see that arguments lead people to actually, this is called the boomerang effect. When we argue, we can argue constructively, when we argue destructively, telling each other why we are wrong, why we are immoral, why our attitude should not be expressed in this manner. We become defensive.
现在，我们经常看到争论实际上导致人们——这被称为“回旋镖效应”。当我们争论时，我们可以建设性地争论；当我们破坏性地争论时，互相告诉对方为什么我们错了，为什么我们是不道德的，为什么我们的态度不应该以这种方式表达。我们变得防御。
And when we become defensive, we cannot change. We actually bolster our initial attitude because we drove into parallel lanes. We didn't listen to one another. We thought about how we're going to counteract. And this is what we see. We see bolstering of the initial attitudes. With listening, we see the opposite.
当我们变得防御时，我们无法改变。我们实际上加强了我们最初的态度，因为我们驶入了平行的车道。我们没有倾听彼此。我们思考的是如何反击。这就是我们所看到的。我们看到最初态度的加强。通过倾听，我们看到了相反的结果。
Because when you give the person the psychological safety, the social connection, say, I don't need to agree with you, but I validate, I acknowledge what you're saying. I validate your emotions. Then people can see the person behind the attitude. Now, by the way, in a paper that is forthcoming in the same journal, Journal of Personality and Social Psychology,
因为当你给对方心理安全感、社会联系时，说：“我不需要同意你，但我认可，我承认你所说的。我认可你的情绪。”那么人们就能看到态度背后的人。顺便说一下，在同一本期刊《人格与社会心理学杂志》即将发表的一篇论文中，
we found that during disagreements, when speakers receive high quality listening, they report increased subjective well-being during this disagreement relative to lower quality of listening. And this was explained by satisfaction of basic psychological needs, autonomy, relatedness, and competence. And another interesting finding there was that we found that listening was more important than agreement
我们发现，在分歧期间，当说话者得到高质量的倾听时，与低质量的倾听相比，他们报告在分歧期间的主观幸福感增加。这可以通过基本心理需求——自主性、亲近感和能力的满足来解释。另一个有趣的发现是，我们发现倾听比同意
to people's subjective well-being. So maybe winning an argument isn't whether I spoke louder than the other person is whether I felt really listened to and learned new things about my attitude. Perhaps this is the real win that we want to achieve, but the finding that listening, and it was conversation between strangers, so I don't want to make, you know, extrapolate as a scientist and really careful in what I'm making of my studies, but there is some preliminary evidence that listening, if we, I'll say it cautiously,
对人们的主观幸福感更重要。所以也许赢得一场争论不是看我是否比对方说得更大声，而是看我是否真的感到被倾听，并学到了关于我态度的新东西。也许这就是我们想要实现的真正胜利，但发现倾听——而且这是陌生人之间的对话，所以我不想作为一个科学家进行推断，我对我的研究结果非常谨慎——但有一些初步证据表明，倾听，如果我谨慎地说，
at least as important as having someone agree with us. In our studies, we found that it's actually more important. I want to talk about how we learn to listen. I mean, for parents and caregivers who might be listening to us, I hope they're listening, how can they teach their children to be better listeners? At what age do we begin to internalize the concepts necessary to become good listeners? You know, one of my dreams is that listening will be taught in schools, from elementary school to high school to universities. Like we teach reading, we teach writing.
至少和有人同意我们一样重要。在我们的研究中，我们发现它实际上更重要。我想谈谈我们如何学习倾听。我的意思是，对于可能正在听我们节目的父母和看护人，我希望他们在听，他们如何能教他们的孩子成为更好的倾听者？我们在什么年龄开始内化成为好倾听者所需的概念？你知道，我的梦想之一是倾听能在学校里被教授，从小学到高中再到大学。就像我们教阅读、教写作一样。
We need to teach listening. By the way, as parents, before we try to train our kids, we need to train ourselves. The kids we learn from the example. And interestingly, by the way, when in the workplace, managers report that listening is one of the top three skills that they, look for in an employee. However, most of their study showing focused on business schools who train future leaders,
我们需要教倾听。顺便说一下，作为父母，在我们试图训练孩子之前，我们需要训练我们自己。孩子们从榜样身上学习。有趣的是，顺便说一下，在职场中，经理们报告说倾听是他们在一份工作中寻找的前三大技能之一。然而，他们的大部分研究都集中在培养未来领导者的商学院，
the vast majority of them do not teach listening. A dean in a very prestigious business school told me once, everyone knows how to listen. We need to teach our students how to speak. Then we did together some listening exercises and they learned that it's not so easy. But per your question, my dream is from,
绝大多数商学院并不教授倾听。一所非常著名的商学院的院长曾经告诉我：“每个人都知道如何倾听。我们需要教我们的学生如何说话。”然后我们一起做了一些倾听练习，他们了解到这并不那么容易。但就你的问题而言，我的梦想是从一年级开始教授它，也教给成年人。这并不意味着我们成长得越多，我们就越善于倾听。如果我们不训练这块肌肉，年龄并不能保证我们变得擅长它。现在，当我们谈论父母和孩子时，问题变得更加复杂。因为我经常收到的一个问题是：“好吧，我该如何倾听我的孩子？”他们不想和我说话，因为作为父母，我们非常……
from first grade to teach it and also to adults. It doesn't mean that the more we grow doesn't mean we become better at listening. If we don't train this muscle, age will not guarantee that we become good at it. Now, when we talk about parents and kids, the issue become more complex. Because a question that I often receive is like, okay, how do I listen to my child? and they don't want to talk to me because as parents, we are very,
因为我们想帮助我们的孩子，我们想拥抱他们、保护他们，我们非常急于给出建议。现在，通常，孩子们并不想要建议。寻求建议和给出建议之间有很大的区别。现在，当我们的孩子收到建议时，
because we want to help our kids and we want to cover them, hug them and protect them, we are very quick to give advice. Now, often, the kids do not want an advice. There is a big difference between seeking advice and giving advice. Now, when our kids receive an advice,
就像每个人一样，顺便说一下，他们没有要求的建议，他们会变得恼火。现在，这适用于每一次对话，但对于父母的倾听尤其如此。所以我将用一个故事来解决这个问题。我为导游举办了一个倾听研讨会，其中一位经理来找我，她是一位母亲。她告诉我：“我家里有一个青春期的孩子，
like every person, by the way, that they did not ask for, they become irritated. Now, it's true for every conversation, but it's especially true with parental listening. So I will address this with a story. I gave a listening workshop for tour guides, and one of the managers came to me, and she's a mother. She told me I have an adolescence at home,
我无法和她交流。她对我生气，什么都做不了，我该怎么办？”所以我告诉她，让我们尝试一件事。下次她来找你谈话时，克制住不要给她建议。只是倾听她。然后告诉我结果如何。
and I can converse with her. Like, she gets upset with me and everything, and what can I do? So I told her, let's try one thing. Next time she comes to talk to you, refrain from giving her advice. Just listen to her. And tell me how it went.
实际上她后来打电话给我说：“不，她向我敞开了心扉，然后她想再次和我说话。”现在，说起来容易做起来难。顺便说一下，这就是我们所说的“倾听态度”。它可以被培养，但并不容易。倾听态度是你相信仅仅通过倾听就能帮助对方的程度。现在，你拥有的倾听态度越强，
And actually she called me after and said, no, she opened up to me and then she wanted to speak with me again. Now, it's easier said than done. This is what we call, by the way, a listening attitude. And it can be developed, but it's not easy. A listening attitude is the extent you, you believe that you will help the other person by listening alone. Now, the stronger, the listening attitude you have,
你就越能防止自己在没人要求时给出未经请求的建议或反馈。所以这对于孩子和父母来说，建议是一个大问题。对于那些糟糕的人，顺便说一下，倾听是有敌人的。我把它呈现得好像一切都很好。与其他干预措施相比，倾听是非常安全的，顺便说一下。但有一些敌人，你知道，隐喻意义上的。倾听的敌人之一，关于倾听的误解之一是倾听是免费的。
the more you will prevent yourself from giving an unsolicited advice or feedback when no one asked for. So this is with kids and parents, like the advice is a big issue. For people who are bad, but there are enemies, by the way, to listening. I'm presenting it like it's all. And it's relative to other interventions, listening is very safe, by the way. But there are enemies in, you know, metaphorically. One of the enemies of listening, one of the misperceptions about listening is that listening is free.
我们的倾听基本上是保持沉默，等待对方说完话。倾听不是免费的。它是昂贵的。它需要意志。它需要动力、能量、时间和努力。现在，我们这些资源是有限的。当你谈到看护人或人们时，例如，社会工作者或护士，人们，职业治疗师，顺便说一下，我现在正在对自闭症青少年进行倾听训练。人们，我通过这个研讨会学到了很多有趣的事情。
Our listening is basically being silent and waiting until the other person finishes speaking. Listening is not free. It is costly. It requires volition. It requires motivation, energy, time, and effort. Now, we have limited resources of these resources. When you talked about caregivers or people, for example, social workers or nurses, people, occupational therapist, I'm now doing, by the way, listening, training to autistic youngsters. People are, I'm learning so many interesting things using this workshop.
现在，在这些环境中，倾听者，也就是护士、社会工作者，经常经历所谓的“同情疲劳”。因为，你知道，当我们听到，当我们参与到困难的对话、负面内容、创伤性内容、二次创伤中时，我们捕捉到这种负面情绪，或者我们捕捉到这些困难。这通常会导致这个行业的人经历同情疲劳。我不能再有同理心了。我不能再有同情心了，因为这是一种有限的资源。我认为应该做的是
Now, in these settings, listeners, so nurses, social workers often experience what is called compassion fatigue. Because, you know, when we hear, when we are engaged in conversations that are difficult conversations, negative content, traumatic content, secondary trauma, we catch this negative emotions or we catch these difficulties. and this often leads people in this profession to experience compassion fatigue. I cannot be empathic anymore. I cannot be compassionate anymore because it's a limited resource. What I think should be done
他们需要有人倾听他们，以便他们能够做到这一点。但重要的是要意识到倾听是有成本的。像每种资源一样，它需要以明智的方式分配，因为我们没有无穷无尽的资源。你知道，你写过倾听者可能面临的另一个挑战，那就是当有人不断重复同一个故事或抱怨时，你该如何反应？
is they need people to listen to them in order to do it. But it's important to realize that listening has costs. And like every resource, it needs to be allocated in a smart way because we don't have an endless amount of it. You know, you wrote about another challenge that some listeners may face, which is how do you react when someone keeps repeating the same story or complaint?
那么在那种情况下，你如何有效地倾听？这是一个难题。通常，你知道我们是在谈论人类行为，所以没有一种万能的解决方案。但根据我的经验，通常当有人重复同样的事情时，就像一张坏掉的CD。我不知道今天的年轻人是否知道什么是CD，但我没有更好的等价物。
So how can you listen effectively in those kinds of situations? That's a tough one. Usually, and you know we're talking about human behavior, so there is no one size fits all the solution. But from my experience, usually when someone repeats the same, it's like a broken CD. I don't know if young people today will know what the CD is, but I don't have a better equivalent.
所以就像一张坏掉的CD，当有人一遍又一遍地重复同样的内容时，通常有什么东西卡在那里了。现在，在这种情况下，我发现有益的做法是尝试识别并反映这种重复所表现出的情绪。例如，假设我正在告诉你一个关于我的经理对我有多不公平的故事。我一直在重复，重复。现在，如果你反映内容，我只会一遍又一遍地重复我所说的话。
So like a broken CD, when someone repeats the same content over and over, there is usually something stuck there. Now, in this situation, What I found to be beneficial is to try to identify and reflect the emotion that is manifest this repetition. So for example, let's say that I'm telling you a story about how unfair my manager was towards me. And I keep repeating, repeating. Now, if you'll reflect on the content, I will just repeat what I say, what I said again and again and again.
就像一张坏掉的CD，当一个人反复重复同样的内容时，通常是因为有什么东西卡住了。在这种情况下，我发现有效的方法是尝试识别并反映出这种重复背后所体现的情绪。举个例子，假设我正在向你讲述我的经理对我有多么不公平，而且我一直在重复，不断地重复。如果你只是回应我所说的内容，我只会一遍又一遍地重复我刚才说过的话。
What will behave for how to move from this point on and to advance the conversation is often try to reflect on the emotion. So, for example, so if I understand, if what the emotion I hear from you is that you feel very angry, you feel hurt, you feel even betrayed by this manager. Is that correct? And usually when the emotion is accurately, accurately perceived by the listener, then the speaker can move to a more deep level of the conversation. Why do you feel this way? So there are ways, but it's not easy. It's not easy in this context. Let's talk about AI, which seems to be everywhere these days.
从这一点出发，为了推进对话，通常会尝试反思情绪。例如，如果我理解得没错，我从你这里听到的情绪是你感到非常愤怒、受伤，甚至觉得被这位经理背叛了。是这样吗？通常当倾听者准确地感知到情绪时，说话者就能进入更深层次的对话。你为什么会有这种感觉？所以是有方法的，但这并不容易。在这种情况下并不容易。让我们谈谈人工智能，它似乎在当今无处不在。
It's a huge part of our life and getting bigger. And people are turning to chatbots for emotional support. and advice. Is AI a good listener or is there something that's fundamentally missing in those interactions that you might have with AI or a chatbot? So I think that AI to date, you know, it's advancing exponentially. So, you know, we talk about it today. It will probably be in a completely different phase even in one month or so.
它是我们生活中重要的一部分，而且影响力还在不断扩大。人们正转向聊天机器人寻求情感支持和建议。人工智能是一个好的倾听者吗？还是说在与人工智能或聊天机器人的互动中，本质上缺少了某些东西？我认为人工智能发展至今，正呈指数级增长。所以，我们今天谈论它，可能一个月后它就处于一个完全不同的阶段了。
I don't think that what we're actually doing with AI is listening. per se. Often people, let's be, okay, so especially for young people, when you tell to them listening,
我不认为我们现在用人工智能所做的事情就是倾听本身。通常人们，好吧，特别是年轻人，当你对他们说倾听时，
they think about texting through WhatsApp to one another. So with texting, what is missing is all the, you know, non-verbal components of listening. But, you know, nowadays you can even do it
他们想到的是通过WhatsApp互相发短信。所以对于发短信来说，缺失的是所有非语言的倾听成分。但是，如今你甚至可以通过
with video or audio. So let's say that we can do it with, we're doing it with video and audio. So the AI can be a terrific listener, but there is a problem. with the way that AI is doing the listener because AI is currently built
视频或音频来做到这一点。所以假设我们可以通过视频和音频来做到。人工智能可以成为一个极好的倾听者，但人工智能的倾听方式存在一个问题，因为人工智能目前被构建为
to be very agreeable, to validate us, to... It's almost actively listening, right? I mean, it's using those techniques. Exactly, exactly. It doesn't challenge us. Now, we talked about high quality listening, but there are different types of listening.
非常讨人喜欢，来验证我们……这几乎是积极倾听，对吧？我的意思是，它正在使用那些技巧。没错，没错。它不会挑战我们。现在，我们谈论了高质量的倾听，但倾听有不同的类型。
There is challenging, listening, there is, and not always supportive listening, like the AI does in a very perfect way, but it's very supportive. It is not always the listening that the person needs. And often, by the way, it can have very harmful consequences. So just for as an example, there is a study back from 2020 where employees vented about their managers and the researchers ask them, which type of listening do you want to receive?
有挑战性的倾听，有不总是支持性的倾听，就像人工智能以一种非常完美的方式所做的那样，但它是非常支持性的。这并不总是人们所需要的倾听。顺便说一句，这通常会产生非常有害的后果。举个例子，2020年有一项研究，员工抱怨他们的经理，研究人员问他们，你想接受哪种类型的倾听？
Supportive listening, like the AI does. There was no AI back then, but supportive listening, which is basically very similar to what AI does, or challenging listening, which is listening that a listening that tries to reframe the situation. So the vast majority of participants chose the supportive listener. Yeah, I'm inventing. I want a supportive listener.
支持性倾听，就像人工智能做的那样。那时还没有人工智能，但支持性倾听，基本上与人工智能所做的非常相似，或者挑战性倾听，即试图重构情况的倾听。所以绝大多数参与者选择了支持性倾听者。是的，我在发泄。我想要一个支持性的倾听者。
However, the listening style that was more beneficial for this angry employees was actually challenging listening because it helped them reframe the situation and feel less angry. Now, the reason I'm saying it in response to the AI question is sometimes we need a listener that challenges us. For example, if I am depressed and the AI validates me, I might become. more depressed or more anxious. There are stories about how an AI helped a person, I think a young, I don't know if it was a boy or a girl, write their suicide letter. I think it was in the US and I think there was more than one case.
然而，对这些愤怒的员工来说，更有益的倾听风格实际上是挑战性倾听，因为它帮助他们重构了情况，并感到不那么愤怒了。现在，我之所以在回应人工智能问题时提到这一点，是因为有时我们需要一个挑战我们的倾听者。例如，如果我抑郁了，而人工智能验证了我，我可能会变得更抑郁或更焦虑。有一些关于人工智能如何帮助一个人（我想是一个年轻人，不知道是男孩还是女孩）写下遗书的故事。我想是在美国，而且我认为不止一个案例。
Now, this is the thing that scares me because the AI is too validating. And we wrote about it in a recent paper in the puzzles of listening and the paradoxes of listening that everyone thinks that, okay, so the person-centered, supportive listening is the best type of listening always. No, it depends on the situation. Now, here you have to have, so the AI is perfect, is perfect in imitating human behavior. Perfect, better than us, better than human. But it cannot understand human behavior because it's not human. So it imitates it perfectly, but it doesn't understand.
现在，这正是让我害怕的事情，因为人工智能太容易验证我们了。我们在最近一篇关于倾听的难题和倾听的悖论的论文中写道，每个人都认为，以人为本的支持性倾听总是最好的倾听方式。不，这取决于情况。现在，你必须拥有……所以人工智能在模仿人类行为方面是完美的，是完美的。完美，比我们更好，比人类更好。但它无法理解人类行为，因为它不是人类。所以它模仿得非常完美，但它并不理解。
And we still need this understanding when the situations are difficult. So, so, so, so, and this is, this is a big question with, with, with the, the, one of the, again, I'm not, of course, I'm not against you, you know, AI is the, it's like, you know, the transition from the font, like to my daughters do not know what's, like before the smartphone, like before the smartphone was the dinosaur era, right? So, you know, like, like the transition to smartphone that it's, it's here to stay. It's a different level of evolution. However, one of the things that I'm interested
当情况困难时，我们仍然需要这种理解。所以，这是一个大问题……当然，我并不反对人工智能，你知道，这就像从固定电话到智能手机的转变，我的女儿们不知道智能手机之前是什么样，就像智能手机之前是恐龙时代，对吧？所以，你知道，这种向智能手机的转变是不可逆转的。这是进化到了一个不同的水平。然而，我感兴趣的一件事是
to see how it will work is what it will do to the social connection to the amount of conversation that people convey. There is a new study, a very interesting study, that found that people speak more than on average and the study was until 2019. 330 words less on average per day. So people speak less.
看看它将如何运作，它会对社会联系、人们进行的对话量产生什么影响。有一项新的研究，一项非常有趣的研究发现，人们说话比平均水平多……这项研究截止到2019年。平均每天少说330个词。所以人们说得更少了。
And if people speak less with one another, it means that they also listen less. Now, this was before the AI era. So now with the AI, if we turn only to AI, because it's validating, we're always correct. If I will lead an argument, if I tell the AI that they had an argument, you know, I'm always correct. I'm never correct, you know, I'm, you know,
如果人们之间说得更少，意味着他们听得也更少。现在，这是在人工智能时代之前。所以现在有了人工智能，如果我们只转向人工智能，因为它会验证我们，我们总是正确的。如果我要进行一场争论，如果我告诉人工智能我们发生了争论，你知道，我总是正确的。我从来没有错，你知道，我是……
when a man arguing with his wife, is never correct. Now for DA, I can tell me I'm correct. It's great. It's a great avenue to, but it's not realistic. And this is something that will be interesting to see how it develops. Well, Dr. Hitchikoff, I want to thank you for joining me today. This has been a very interesting conversation. Thank you. Thank you for inviting me. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingofpsychology.org or on Apple, YouTube, Spotify, or wherever you get your podcast. And if you like what you heard, please follow us and leave a review.
当一个男人和他的妻子争论时，他从来不是正确的。现在对于人工智能，它可以告诉我我是正确的。这太棒了。这是一个很好的途径，但它不现实。这是未来值得观察如何发展的事情。好的，Hitchikoff博士，我想感谢你今天加入我。这是一次非常有趣的对话。谢谢。谢谢你的邀请。你可以在我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org或Apple、YouTube、Spotify或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。如果你喜欢你所听到的，请关注我们并留下评论。
If you have comments or ideas for future episodes, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你对未来的剧集有评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由Lee Wynerman制作。感谢收听美国心理学会的节目。我是Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。